a chorus against those who follow the
United States or Iran it's day 100 for
Iraq's pro-democracy demonstrators
who've been camping out in multiple
cities they say their demands are simple
give us rulers who have honor and
corruption and foreign influence and
hold early elections Iraq is not a war
ground we want the government to leave
we want homes we want dignity we wanted
independent Iraq with no external
influence their pressure has forced out
prime minister Adel Abdel aati but weeks
after his resignation he still in charge
albeit in a caretaker capacity and
Iraqis are still no closer to an interim
government acceptable to all parties we
want to live in dignity we need a united
country with sovereignty we do not want
others to interfere this interference
happened because of the weak leadership
we've had since 2003 this is by far the
largest crowd that we've seen in Baghdad
in recent weeks people have been coming
here from all corners of the country
they are saying that they're against the
influence of the United States as well
as Iran in their country the festive
atmosphere here makes it difficult to
imagine that it's the same city which
was on edge just 48 hours ago
missile warnings helicopters in the air
and threats of a major conflict between
Iran and the US but it's still a
pressing issue in Baghdad's corridors of
power the Iraqi PM's request for the
u.s. to send a mission to discuss
foreign forces the drawl has been all
but ignored by the United States we are
happy to continue the conversation with
the Iraqis about what the right
structure is our mission set there is
very clear we've been there to perform a
training mission to help the Iraqi
security forces be successful and to
continue the campaign against Isis we
also have today NATO team that's here at
the State Department working to develop
a plan which will get burden-sharing
right in the region as well
but since the assassination of Qasem
Soleimani Anibal Maciel Mohandas
anti-isil operations have been suspended
and some coalition troops have been
relocated for their safety and the
government here is questioning when
foreign troops are hunkering down to
protect themselves what's the point in
keeping them in Iraq
Osama bin zayed al jazeera Baghdad